the other thing that links our guy just
everyone started very young now been the
last time a year that we enjoyed very
much your early work on the voyage of
the Mimi we're not gonna show anymore
thank you do believe in it because it is
worth seriously you really need to
google it you started widget modeling
you started you were quite young when
you started modeling I was ashore and so
I know I mean yes but not like proper
[Applause]
you did some extraordinary work as a
child actor I mean take this Meryl
Streep that's a nice food that's in the
piece I did a kind of energy Robinson
thing where I was like tonight with lala
land in mind we're going to focus on the
early dancing career of mr. Ryan Gosling
only video you have tonight is dance
true you were in can you tell us about
because apparently young dancers they
could be quite vicious it's a cutthroat
business to get out I was on some kind
of Canadian Star Search and I somehow
made it to the finals and my main
competition were these two twins who
were tap dancers and they were dancing
to phil collins 2hearts and they had big
heart-shaped bows and they were just
they were the ones to beat so I remember
you know wishing them luck and going on
stage and I was getting ready to start
was dancing the everybody dance now by
C&C Music Factory of course getting
ready to start which is this is how you
started a winning dance number if you
wanna know into the just off stage and
the two twins are standing there it's
like the twins from the shining and
they're just going like this
[Laughter]
that means more right I just shimmied my
way all the way to it to that trophy to
that tiny little trophy all it's a tall
girl true but obviously it's not you're
in it in it yeah that was the was that
the that was the point that was the
gimmick they let me dance there for free
because I was a guy because if you had a
guy you you would win oh okay yeah so
are you are you ready to see the I
believe you're dancing to Kathy Dennis's
classic touch me
did the troupe of a named Ryan it was
elite dance studio
old enough to know better
[Music]
[Applause]
I wish I could say someone said here you
have to wear this that was my idea I
thought I have a vision for this number
and silverhammer pants the silverhammer
Prancer we gave them enough of a shot we
gave up with hammer but I don't I think
we should should have kept them going no
yeah
[Music]